y ahora
[Música]
quiero hablarte de una fiesta que
invierta el mundo donde todo es alegría
y de donde todo de felicidad es el
carnaval era el culto al dios baco al
dios del vino
era tan poderosa que la gente se
divertía tanto que la misma iglesia
católica no pudo cortar la entonces la
doméstico dijo está bien pueden hacer su
carnaval pero eso sí siempre antes de la
semana santa que quiere decir esto puede
hacer todo lo que quieran y después a
guardar
creo que la única coincidencia feliz que
ha habido en la conquista ha sido que
coincidió con febrero este carnaval qué
quiere decir la lluvia es fuerte en
febrero como ustedes saben al menos en
la sierra aquí no aquí nunca llueve pero
el concepto que me parece interesante es
que una comunidad que vive en relación
con la vida que es parte de la
naturaleza también tenía esos rituales
alegres en el momento de carnaval
entonces coincidió perfectamente la idea
de un carnaval europeo en calzado justo
con rito de fertilidad en adelante esto
yo era mucho más jovencito y comencé
estudiando el carnaval era justamente mi
concepto era un antropólogo bastante
alto rubio blanco y estaba haciendo en
todo caso un estudio de esta gente
exótica estos conceptos raros
y ahí estaba yo con una cámara moderna y
aquí veo en la foto que los niños están
viendo a la cámara de fotos y también a
la cámara de vídeo el concepto era de
qué exorcizada yo bastante la gente
son como están haciendo las cosas y veía
comparsas veía gente borracha vive el
mundo invertido
repentinamente un grupo de jóvenes
borrachos de la comunidad se acerca
detrás mío y estaba muy concentrado con
la cámara
viene con ellos a abuso me bajan el
pantalón
la comunidad vio algo que yo jamás he
visto mi propio trasero
el antropólogo foráneo quedaba deshecho
todo el mundo se reía de mí así como
ustedes se ríen y decidió también reírme
que me quedaba ni modo y al mismo tiempo
descubrir dos cosas que quiero compartir
contigo una que la risa nos une y la
otra que la risa relativiza ese poder
algo tan valioso como la risa no así
estudiado
aristóteles dijo que la risa era
simplemente una forma de humillar que
era una forma de denotar la inferioridad
de alguien frente a la superioridad de
otro el que se burlaba de notar su
superioridad y el que era humillado
bueno era víctima de algún tipo de
efecto que el enfático
pues bien lamentablemente aristóteles no
va más allá y si lo hizo aristóteles la
gente le hace caso la risa como
humillación no sé ustedes pero me parece
bastante limitado
sin embargo si vamos al centro de lima y
8 trabajo de campo con los cómicos de la
calle y siempre me ha ido mal o sea me
asomo a ver el espectáculo y claro en un
gringo dice gringo te gusta el perú
llévatelo pues y todo el mundo se
carcajea de mí nuevamente
y nuevamente aprendo eso que la risa nos
une si sabemos reírnos de nosotros
mismos y es algo que creo que los
peruanos estamos aprendiendo
el menú
ya no me da tan mal en el amor tengo que
decir
pero es algo que compartimos todos
entienden la auto burla y gracias al mem
hemos aprendido que muchos nosotros por
ejemplo pro casting amos nos va mal en
la vida nos va mal el amor a veces y
está auto burla ha permitido que seamos
comunidad al momento de auto burlarnos
de nosotros ustedes no tienen idea para
esta charla todo lo que tuve que auto
burlar para superar todo el miedo en
general es eso entonces está bien
aristóteles habla de la humillación la
humillación tiene un problema urbanos de
un de otros es problemático pero
reconocer nuestra propia limitación si
es una cosa buena aprender a reírnos de
nosotros mismos al menos yo lo hice
porque todo se reía de mí
ahora si aristóteles dice algo van a
pasar 2500 años para que alguien les dé
la contra freud según freud sostenía que
el humor más bien era un caballo de
troya o sea un vehículo por el cual
subrepticiamente o escondidas metes un
mensaje distinto
como te lo explico como una válvula de
escape o sea hay un montón de tensiones
que tenemos en la sociedad prejuicios
sociales no sé sexo no sé racismo
machismo cosas que están prohibidas y a
través del humor se liberan porque
porque quien cuenta un chiste está
haciendo eso nada más contando un chiste
y quien se ríe está pasando un buen
momento pues bien
eso de ahí es interesante porque
entonces a través del humor decimos
cosas que no nos atrevemos a decir si
bien el humor hace una válvula de escape
para cuestiones que son negativas
también ha sido muy positivo porque
gracias al humor podemos decir otras
cosas que no nos atreveríamos y ahora
entendemos por quinché expert el bufón
siempre le dice sus verdades al rey
este lo hicimos en el mes esta
universidad
dedíquense al mundo académico es muy
bonito pero tiene sus cosas
pero fue una forma de catarsis porque
eso lo hiciste
pues bien grandes como son tanto freud
como aristóteles no nos explican que nos
hace reír unos nos dice que es para
humillar el otro nos dice que es una
válvula de escape
es decir con la teoría de la
incongruencia que ha sido desarrollado
por varios psicólogos no tiene un autor
específico que se determina qué es lo
que nos hace reír y eso quiero compartir
la risa es una sorpresa nuestra mente
tiene la capacidad de predecir qué va a
pasar al menos en un milímetro de un
microsegundo
si hay una sorpresa la atención
inconsciente se relaja y generó la
reacción respiratoria llamada risa
entonces por ejemplo si yo estoy
caminando ustedes pueden predecir que
seguiré caminando un milímetro más pero
si me caigo me rompo el cerebro este eso
generaría sorpresa
espero que me ayuden si pasáis pero en
fin risa y risa al fin y al cabo es la
sorpresa es lo que nos genera risa ahora
entendemos varias cosas las cosas las
ideas que nos impactan de buenas a
primeras
las ideas contradictorias como dice
charly parla o sea que se unen las ideas
sorpresivas y las acciones sorpresivas
tenéis que nos guste tanto los bloopers
las caídas los tortazos en la cara
nuevamente o sea sí sí recomiendo que
sean profesores porque se vive una vida
muy intensa yo justamente tengo esta
dinámica con mis alumnos que me
sorprenden a veces yo tenía una alumna
jessica que yo le decía jessica cómo te
fue en los exámenes ella me decía bueno
al esto lo importante es que tengo salud
me sorprendía y otro al de una casa la
llamada como yo álex y éstas me
encantaba
álex estudia
y una vez lo veo vagando totalmente
tirado en el pasto y le digo y tú me
dijiste ese es tu día
gracias al menos al menos se ganó mi
simpatía pero no me nota pero entienden
las otras
pero se dan cuenta de la sorpresa como
elemento y nuevamente el meme la
sorpresa que nos da el mensaje
como profesor tengo que decir que fuiste
sin ese pero ya me fuiste pero ya vale
por el meme y si se dan cuenta usado
memes con animalitos porque unas cosas
que nos sorprende es cuando el animal se
comporta como humano nosotros
proyectamos en él una actitud humana
ahora entendemos por qué los gatos se
han vuelto a invadir los muros desde
egipto que no pasaba eso estaba por todo
el internet porque nos sorprenden verlos
con una actitud humana o que proyectamos
en ellos una actitud humana
ok entonces hemos visto que la risa es
importante
toda la cultura tiene un personaje
lúdico
que hace bromas que chiquito que le
vence a los grandes en todas las
mitologías humanas en todas
los nórdicos tienen a lo que ustedes lo
conocen por marvel pero si existe como
dios y una vez por travieso destruyó el
mundo
los franceses tienen al zorro ferdinand
que hace bromas a los humanos en los
mitos de abajo
el coyote roba el fuego a los dioses
para fregar y después lo entrega a los
humanos
por ryan un antropólogo llamó a estos
personajes trickster bromistas el
trickster es un hacedor de caos
porque toda cultura humana gusta tener
un trickster una señor de caos incluso
en la modernidad en el cómic está de
moda joker es nuestro trickster por
excelencia moderno porque estos payasos
sagrados bueno justamente porque la
cultura humana y no la nuestra que tiene
el nivel cero como la seriedad la normal
sino en general todas las culturas
tradicionales saben que la risa produce
cierto pequeño caos agradable y eso nos
ayuda a concentrarnos en el mensaje es
decir convierte lo inconsciente en
pensamiento
también se dice que estos personajes
lúdicos nos ayudan a entender a la
sociedad porque se comporta exactamente
al contrario de lo que debiera la
sociedad entonces si yo pongo este
aparato de cabeza sigue siendo este
aparato que puede entenderlo mejor o sea
nos ayuda a entendernos por oposición
hay otros antropólogos que dicen que tal
vez sea una metáfora una hermosa
metáfora de que la vida es absurda
nosotros estudiamos cubrimos todas las
leyes nos esforzamos hacemos todo y todo
nos sale mal bueno tal vez el 30 de
estos personajes lúdicos sean esa
metáfora
como otro polo tengo la obligación de
invitarlos a conocer a un trickster
andino y yo quiero mucho cuando estoy en
trabajo de campo yo me llevo bien con
los niños porque los niños son los
únicos que comprenden a los antropólogos
porque somos como niños pues haciendo
preguntas sin saber cayendo nos haciendo
bien torpes
a los niños les damos risa entonces les
gusta conversar con nosotros y
compartimos cuentos yo les cuento sobre
marcelo diz y ellos me cuentan sobre
mitología andina y siempre he
descubierto que el trickster del
personaje lúdico andino es el pequeño
que por alguna razón que no sé el zorro
es el ingenuo entonces quiero compartir
un cuento cortito que me contaban los
niños y que me encanta y era que una vez
un cuy estaba comiendo alfalfa en la
granja de un granjero
el granjero lo atrapó y lo amarró mañana
que te voy a comer che tal
en la noche apareció el zorro y vio al
cuy intentando de samarrá
hijo hermano q y que pasa estás amarrado
sabes que creo que te voy a comer y dijo
no no estoy amargado es parte de un
ritual el granjero quiere que me case
con su hija y encima quiere que yo como
gallinas sino como gallinas tampoco me
gusta su hija y el sordo dijo
sabes que a mí sí me gusta la hija del
granjero y así como gallinas
y el coi dijo si quiere este cambio de
lugar pero me vas a ver una y el zorro
dijo bueno lo desató y el culo a todos
al zorro pero de manera así fire te coge
un poco de alfalfa y se fue
en la mañana siguiente el granjero llega
y dice metamorfosis además realiza un
cuy y ahora tengo un zorro y esto lo
dijo no lo que pasa que quiero casarme
con tu hija lamentablemente en los
cuentos los animales hablan en este caso
no convino porque el granjero la barrosa
palace
entonces el zorro estaba feliz porque
decía bueno así es el ritual de doloroso
así son los rituales en los andes
sin embargo el campesino o el granjero
dijo mamá aquí pasa algo lo que ha
pasado y el zorro le explicó el cambio
sí entiendo tú no tienes la culpa de ser
tan soso y el cuy no tiene la culpa de
ser tan vivo lo liberó
así liberados los dos animalitos me han
enseñado muchas cosas como muchas cosas
me han enseñado los cómicos de la calle
como muchas cosas me ha enseñado a la
gente en carnaval en los andes' como
tantas cosas se ha aprendido cuando se
han burlado de mí y se siguen burlando
de mí y aprendí a burlarme y aprendido
algo que creo que nos puede ayudar a
todos sobre todo una sociedad que se
toma tan en serio que las culturas
veneran la risa primero porque la risa
une una personas no existe nada que nos
dé más unión que ese eco que da a
reírnos juntos
porque crees el que comprendimos la
broma y pasamos el buen momento juntos
también la risa una ideas ideas
totalmente contrarias y eso es lo que
sorprende lo sagrado y lo profano lo
serio lo no tan serio lo absurdo lo
lógico o lo simplemente lógico y lo
vivencial eso une la risa y gracias a
eso nos reímos porque unimos cosas
absurdas y por último es algo que me
enseñó el puig realmente y es algo que
quiero compartirles también de forma muy
muy de corazón
es la idea de qué
si tú puedes reírte de una situación esa
situación ya no tiene poder sobre ti
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]